dieser Krieg ist für Putin zu Obsession
geworden denn seine Macht braucht den
Sieg um sich zur legitimieren befeuert
von einer Propaganda die das Volk
glauben lässt es gehe um etwas das
größer sei als das eigene Leben
das haben alle Diktatoren perfekt seit
Jahrhunderten gemacht Leute glauben ihre
Heimat zu verteidigen ja von den Feinden
von den Faschisten
ein Wirklichkeit die verteidigen das
putinische kriminelleische
Kleinlützel ein Schweizer Dorf nah der
französischen Grenze der ukrainekrieg
scheint weit entfernt doch für Michael
Schischkin ist der omnipräsent einst
wurde er in Russland als wichtigster
gegenwartsautor gefeiert heute gilt er
dort als Verräter schischin will
wachrütteln zieht Parallelen zwischen
Russland und Nazi-Deutschland der ganze
Hass von Hitler geil Juden das war seine
Obsession ja der ganze Hass von Putin
gilt Ukraine viele Leute
verstehen nicht wie Botin und seine
Macht und seine Diktatur funktioniert
und deshalb muss man die Struktur zeigen
ja und diese Struktur dieser putinischen
kriminellen Diktatur ist eigentlich die
gleiche mit Hitler Diktatur
Hitler habe es geschafft das deutsche
Volk seelisch zu verseuchen Putin habe
dies mit seinem Volk getan so schisskind
mit einer Propaganda in göbbelstil nur
das Heute Moderatorin wie Vladimir
solofi auf diese im russischen
Staatsfernsehen präsentierten der
einzige Friedensplan für die Ukraine sei
deren Auslöschung sagt ein Gast
hier wird die Frage gestellt ob selensky
der Antichrist sei
Entmenschlichung und Enthemmung auf
allen Kanälen
ist von heute versteht wenn Russland
verliert er hat keine Chance zu
überleben
deshalb versucht die Propaganda
versuchen alle Leute und Putin herum
diesen Krieg so total wie möglich zu
machen
der totale Krieg ein Begriff den Joseph
Goebbels geprägt hat mit dieser
Forderung meint der Propagandaminister
Hitlers den Lauf des Zweiten Weltkrieges
verändern zu können
1943 erleidet Deutschland in Stalingrad
eine Niederlage das Regime befindet sich
in seiner größten Krise am 18 Februar
beschwört Göbbels in Berliner
Sportpalast vor 15.000 Hand verlassenen
Besuchern eine totale Kriegsführung der
sich alles unterordnen soll
[Applaus]
diese Situation zu nutzen um sich
sozusagen weiter an die Spitze des
Regimes vorzuarbeiten er wollte die
Verantwortung für die gesamte innere
Kriegsführung übernehmen und diese Rede
war ein wichtiger Bestandteil seiner
Strategie sozusagen diejenigen die in
der Führung noch zögerten mitzureißen
und ihnen zu signalisieren das Volk will
ja den totalen Krieg für den Historiker
Peter Longerich ist die sportpalastrede
Beispiel dafür wie Propaganda stets den
eigenen Machthunger als volkswellen
verkauft sein neues Buch liegt zentrale
Motive dieser Propaganda offen die
selbst Stilisierung als Opfer mächtiger
Feinde denen man in historischer Mission
entgegentritt darum geht es
noch ist die Vernichtung europäischer
Juden geheim doch Göbbels kündigt
bereits an dass Judentum auszurotten
[Musik]
die Nationalsozialisten auch Goebbels
waren ja davon überzeugt dass wenn man
die eigene Bevölkerung in dieses
Jahrhundert Verbrechen involvieren
könnte also dass man sozusagen eine
verschworene Gemeinschaft war sozusagen
ein Mord komplett geschmiedet hatte und
dass das diesen komplett niemand heraus
kam Russlands Regime setzt heute darauf
die eigenen Kriegsverbrechen in der
Ukraine als historische Mission
zurechtfertigen Russland sei umzingelt
von Feinden die das Land vernichten
wollten so die Propaganda
unglaublich aber wahr
wir werden wieder von deutschen Leopard
Panzern bedroht die Kreuze tragen
in russischen Staatsmedien wird offen
davon gesprochen dass ein Krieg mit der
NATO unausweichlich sei der Tod wird als
unvermeidlich propagiert so sprach
solophy of davon dass das Leben maßlos
überbewertet werde
Putin sagte dass es besser sei an der
Front als durch Wodka zu sterben damals
gesagt hat ja wir können nichts anderes
nichts Neues erfinden diese Feinde jetzt
ist das die NATO ja die wollen uns alle
vernichten also entweder wir siegen oder
wir sterben
und die Bevölkerung muss das alles
akzeptieren allmählich verstehen die
Segen können die nicht deshalb müssen
wir alle jetzt sterben
es ist ein apokalyptisches Szenario in
das Putin sein Land verstrickt doch die
Propaganda habe Glück mit einem Volk das
seit Jahrhunderten schweigt
dieses Schweigen formuliert diese
Überlebensstrategie narutismus wird das
Volk schweigt und deshalb ist die
Literatur die Kultur in Russland
so wichtig hat eine ganz andere Rolle ja
denn das einzige was wir diesem
Schweigen
entgegensetzen können das ist das Wort
deshalb versucht die also jede Diktatur
Leute die
etwas sagen ja das laut sagen entweder
zu vernichten oder die sitzen im
Gefängnis oder die müssen immigrieren
eine demokratische Zukunft Russlands ist
für ihn derzeit nicht denkbar all jene
die diese aufbauen könnten hätten das
Land verlassen Russland wiederhole
dieselben Schritte in einem endlosen
Sumpf wie Deutschland vor 80 Jahren
damals hat Göbbels und Hitler verstanden
der Krieg kann nicht gewonnen werden und
verlieren Vermittler und die anderen
bedeutete Tod dasselbe passiert jetzt
guten hat verstanden den Krieg gegen die
Ukraine kann er nicht gewinnen und wenn
sie sterben dann sind die bereit die
ganze Welt mit sich zu nehmen
diesen roten Knopf gehabt hätte er
sicher diesen roten Knopf gedrückt
ich bin sicher
wird vor dem Tode auch diesen roten
Knopf drücken einfach die Frage ist ob
sein Befehl ausgeführt wird oder nicht
selbst wenn Putin einmal weg sein sollte
will schichtkin nicht nach Russland
zurück den Traum jedes russischen
Schriftstellers viel Zeit auf dem Land
zu verbringen könne er auch hier in der
Schweiz verwirklichen nur das seine
Dacia nun klein Lützel heiße